a la sombra de los crímenes de guerra se
cierne sobre gaza en medio de las
negociaciones por el alto el fuego entre
israel y hamás
michelle bachelet alta comisionada de la
onu para los derechos humanos sembró la
duda sobre la legalidad de los ataques
de israel en gaza
si se encuentra que fueron en
discriminados y desproporcionados en su
impacto a civiles y objetivos civiles
estos ataques podrían constituir
crímenes de guerra o unas afirmaciones
que se apoyan en los principios de
distinción y proporcionalidad
establecidos en el derecho internacional
humanitario' queda prohibido lanzar un
ataque cuando se ha de prever que cause
incidentalmente muertos y heridos entre
la población civil daños a bienes de
carácter civil o ambas cosas que sean
excesivos en relación con la ventaja
militar concreta y directa prevista
estos son los argumentos que aporto
bachelet
a pesar de las afirmaciones de israel de
que muchos de estos edificios se
albergaban a grupos armados o se
utilizaban con fines militares no hemos
visto pruebas al respecto aunque
israel tomó una serie de precauciones
los ataques aéreos en esas zonas
densamente pobladas dieron lugar a un
alto nivel de víctimas mortales y
heridos civiles y las críticas se
extendieron también al lanzamiento de
cohetes por parte de hamás que podrían
suponer igualmente una violación del
derecho internacional humanitario por
otro lado también es una violación de la
ley humanitaria internacional establecer
activos militares en áreas densamente
pobladas por civiles o lanzar ataques
desde estos civiles
entretanto ambas partes acordaron acudir
la semana próxima a el cairo para sentar
los términos de la tregua mediada por
egipto se espera asimismo la
participación de la autoridad nacional
palestina designada por eeuu para
tramitar los fondos de reconstrucción de
gaza